now the tragedy of melania's story is
that she is in a state of suffering
sleeping and waiting for her brother to
return to her as she continues to rot
away it also seems like her pride and
ego are damaged she doesn't want to be
the goddess of rot makes it very clear
what she wants to be the blade of mikola
of course we get annoyed at how many
times she tells us this as we most
likely die to her many times over she
will say the same thing as she is
Melania blade of mikola now this might
be a bit of a stretch but someone who is
actually prideful or proud of who they
are doesn't have to voice that to the
world over and over again they don't
have to State the fact that they've
never been defeated they would simply
just take pride in that fact and let
their reputation speak for itself but it
seems like Melania has lost that pride
in herself and is actively trying to
convince herself that she doesn't need
the power of the rot